people tend to hang out with people they
like that usually means people with whom
they share values and community and life
experiences but now it appears that our
political polarization has grown so wide
that Americans who voted differently in
2016 don't want to hang out with each
other that at least is the story from
the Pew Research Center with regard to
leftist that study found that 47% of
Liberal Democrats stated that if a
friend voted for Donald Trump it would
strain the friendship for all Democrats
it was 35 percent for Republicans that
number was just 13 percent when applied
to Hillary Clinton now maybe that number
would have changed to filler 81 but
there's more than a whiff of elemental
scorn Democrats hold for Trump voters
they don't see what was so bad about
Hillary that would necessitate a vote
for Trump they think a vote for Trump
could never be made in a good-faith
effort to help the country but it was
rather just an endorsement of trumps
worst behavior this feeling combined
with the fact that leftists live in
bubbles as Aaron Blake of the Washington
Post points out 47% of people who voted
for Clinton had zero Trump supporting
friends that means the left will
continue to polarize in Hillary only 28%
of Democrats today say they aren't
stressed by talking with those who
differ on Trump which means the vast
majority of Democrats won't even deign
to discuss the issues that leads to
West's knowledge of the typical
Republican and the lazy intellectual
construct that turns Trump voters into
an other to be opposed on grounds of
supposed bigotry that scorn will in turn
drive more and more conservatives into
Trump's arms much of the Trump movement
was built on a reactionary and justified
anger against leftist character
assassination the West's solution
unfortunately seems to be just more
character assassination i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
so many things to talk about today I'm
gonna get to a lot of Hollywood because
I saw at Dunkirk last night and it is
just a stunning film I want to talk
about why it's so good I also want to
show you a trailer that I think is
legitimately one of the worst trailers
with major stars ever made it's really
spectacular ly bad and I loved it so
much because it's so bad but before we
get to any of that first I want to say
thank you
so our sponsor is over at Birch gold so
if you are looking at the economy and
you are seeing the political situation
you feel that perhaps it is volatile
perhaps we have a situation on our hands
or maybe a situation will arise then it
is important that you spend some of your
money and put it in precious metals
that's what Birch gold is for they will
allow you to legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metals IRA that can help you
get some of your money into the safe and
secure asset that precious metals
represent they have never been worth
zero to get your no cost no obligation
can go to birchgold.com slash pen that
is birchgold.com slash bend and as I say
according to basically thanks to IRS tax
law you can move your 401k out of stocks
and bonds and into precious metals Birch
gold group has an A+ rating from the
Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews one of the people I
would trust for investing in precious
metals birchgold.com slash men they will
send you a comprehensive 16 page kit
showing how gold and silver can protect
your savings so go and check them out
let them know that we sent you okay so a
lot of breaking news happening actually
right now so the biggest breaking news
literally broke about five minutes ago
as were as we're filming this is that
Sean Spicer the White House press
secretary has now resigned telling
President Trump he vehemently disagreed
with the appointment of New York
financier Anthony Skinner Moochie as
communications director according to the
New York Times mr. Trump offered mr.
Skinner Moochie the job at 10:00 a.m.
the president requested mr. Spicer stay
on mr. Spicer told mr. Trump people lead
the appointment was a major mistake
according to a person with direct
knowledge of the exchange so that's all
we know at this point Anthony scary mood
for people who don't know was actually a
major Obama donor he ended up moving
into the Republican camp after that I
think that he was on the RNC committee
did the Finance Committee in 2012 and
then he was a supporter of a bunch of
other candidates before he got to Trump
he was a Scott Walker supporter and then
his backer of Jeb Bush
so he's much more sort of establishment
Republican and he's being brought in
apparently Steve Bannon was very unhappy
with the choice of Anthony Skinner
Moochie
it looks like the ascendant wing of the
of the Trump administration is the more
establishment wing of the Trump
administration meaning Anthony Ciara
Moochie Gary Cohen who's a career
Democrat is now being discussed as a
cabinet member of new head of the Fed
Reserve perhaps
well according to NBC News comes is what
Anthony does how he built his business
the guy knows media he's been a good
advocate for the president so I love
this NBC News says another source said
Spicer is definitely staying on well no
now he's gone so it's amazing how you
got all these conflicting reports out of
the Trump administration I think the
reason that secure Moochie is is
considered kind of a nonentity or
somebody who shouldn't have the job buy
a lot of Trump supporters is because he
wasn't on the Trump bandwagon from the
beginning and therefore they think that
he should not be allowed on the inner
circle and this is one of the issues
that Trump has had is trying to figure
out who should be allowed to work with
him who should he trust and there the
people have been with him for a long
time are upset that he seems not to
trust them so much anymore so case in
point be Jeff Sessions so yesterday
Tucker Carlson came out and he was
ripping up President Trump for ripping
on Jeff Sessions as you recall we played
you some of the New York Times interview
yesterday in which in which Trump said
that he would never have hired sessions
if he knew that sessions was going to
recuse himself Tucker Carlson and Ann
Coulter both long time from supporters
came forward and said listen stop
messing with sessions sessions linearly
as supporters he's one of the good guys
on this team particularly with regard to
immigration why are you ripping on your
own base and there is a feeling that
there's some confusion inside the Trump
White House about staffing that is only
being exacerbated by a new report
yesterday from the Washington Post
revealing that academic discussions have
been ongoing at the White House
regarding president Trump's pardon power
apparently they're having lots of talks
about what he can do with pardons can he
preemptively pardon family members can
he preemptively pardon himself with his
really in the Washington Post Trump
possessed advisors about his power to
pardon aides family members and even
himself in connection with the Russia
probe according to one of those people a
second person said Trump's lawyers have
been discussing the president's
pardoning powers among themselves you
know I would imagine that at every point
you have lawyers who are discussing and
discussing the pardon power I'm not sure
what they'd be discussing me exactly
except for
what is he capable of pardoning like if
he pardons a crime now and the new
evidence comes out later does the pardon
cover that maybe there's a lot of talk
this morning about if he would pardon
himself would that actually be legal
could he pardoned himself because
president obviously has plenary pardon
power he can do what he wants with
pardons he can pardoned anybody right
and Gerald Ford pardoned Richard Nixon
so you could have something like that
but are you allowed to pardoned yourself
that would not save his political career
by the way if you pardon yourself the
chances that you're going to be
impeached are pretty high but none of
this looks good okay if you're into the
appearances of politics you can still
believe that Trump has never done
anything wrong that Trump is clean as
the driven snow and that has nothing to
hide but he needs to stop acting like
you had something to hide if he actually
wants to want you to believe that write
the first paragraph of this Washington
Post story says some president Trump's
lawyers are exploring ways to limit or
undercut Special Counsel Robert Muller's
Russia investigation building a case
against what they allege are his
conflicts of interest and discussing the
president's authority to grant pardons
according to people familiar with the
effort yesterday
the spokesperson for his legal effort
regarding the Russian investigation quit
quit he also fired his lawyers and he
hired new lawyers in the Russian
investigation stuff so all of this
doesn't look good I mean if your whole
shtick here is let let all the doors be
open let everything come out I'm
draining the swamp see what I have been
here in my apartment policemen just come
in and investigate and then the next
thing you do is immediately barricade
three of the doors people are going to
start getting a little bit suspicious
and so you know do I think that this
means that Trump is is guilty of
anything no I mean there's there's
alternative explanations that are just
as plausible like for example maybe the
reason he doesn't want Muller digging
into his IRS records is because he is
definitely afraid that Mulder is going
to find that he's not worth anything
like the wealth he said he was worth
right so they weren't two billion bucks
instead of ten billion bucks or maybe
he's worked nothing right maybe it turns
out that he's broke right you just don't
know until you get those IRS records so
maybe he's afraid of that maybe he's
afraid that there's some sort of
ancillary matter dealing with the IRS
that he's going to be held accountable
for and this is the problem with the
Special Counsel investigations again the
Special Counsel investigation was
brought about because President Trump
himself decided to open his big mouth he
fired Comey and then he opened his big
mouth on national television and said
that he did it because of the Russia
investigation that necessitated rod
Rosenstein appointing a special counsel
the biggest opponent Trump has here is
not
Trump the media is getting its material
from Trump he can hate the New York
Times you can think the New York Times
does to get Trump I think that they're
out to get Trump I think they have an
agenda but why is he giving a long
interview with the New York Times in
which he is talking about why he might
fire robber Muller and why Jeff Sessions
had should never have recused himself
it's just foolish it's just foolish
unless there's only two possibilities
here right Trump his worst enemy is his
big mouth he's doing things that look
guilty because he just can't help
himself because he has to talk all the
time
super plausible and the other answer is
it's possible that he actually did
something that makes him guilty and
that's really bad stuff maybe he's doing
all this for a reason maybe as the
Democrat suggests he is actually guilty
of something because if you look at it
from the Democratic perspective let's do
that for a second okay for people on the
right I think it's important that both
sides understand each other so on the
Left understand no hard evidence of
Trump Russia actual collusion has taken
place there is intent to collude from
Trump jr. right there's intense of
collude from Manta for presumably
there's intent to collude from Jared
Kushner but there is no actual
on-the-ground collusion no payoffs no
quid pro quo you know so from the
perspective left you need to understand
we need more evidence in order for us to
acknowledge that Trump actually did
something illegal or even deeply wrong
other than that meeting at this point
and Trump wasn't in that meeting as far
as we know from perspective of the left
I think the right need to understand the
perspective of the left here they're
looking at this and what they see is a
meeting between Trump jr. and a bunch of
Russian lawyers would that was that was
basically paved for that was paved with
a promise they were going to give Trump
negative information about Hillary as
part of Russia's government governmental
effort to support Trump and then you
have Trump firing Mike Flynn for
unspecified reasons after it comes out
that Flynn has connections with Russia
and then you have him firing his FBI
director and saying openly that it's
because of the Russian investigation and
then you have him saying that he should
have fired sessions who never hired
sessions because sessions is recusing
himself from the Russia investigation
and then you have a series of policy
decisions that benefit Russia including
the decision this week by President
Trump not to arm and fund Syrian rebels
against Bashar Assad right which helps
the Russian government so if you're on
the web through looking at all these
indicators and you're saying okay well
you know I feel a lot of dots here it's
hard for me not to connect them and if
you're on the right you have to
understand that perspective because we
did the same thing
President Obama right we were very
suspicious of President Obama I think
it's more justified with Obama than it
is for Trump because I think that
frankly Trump is more likely to make
stupid mistakes and say dumb things then
then Obama was I think Obama was much
more of a president by design but I
think that it's important we understand
where we are so that we don't fall apart
as a country because what I can foresee
happening is some quasi smoking gun
comes out and the right says it doesn't
mean anything unless it means everything
and we just grow further and further
apart as a people and I think that's a
mistake I think we we can disagree on
the implications of these facts but we
should at least acknowledge what the
facts are and why maybe the other guy
thinks what he thinks okay so with all
of that said Trump care continues to
remain controversial and I think here
it's important to point out the
radicalism of the left on on Trump care
so nothing is happening with Trump care
right now okay the repeal and replace
effort is basically stalled because
nobody knows they want to do we've
talked about that for the past several
days but the rhetoric of the left
continues to ratchet up so for example
yeah this professor because himself
would be on say professor that's really
what he calls himself the name is Kevin
Allred and he's a adjunct part-time
lecturer at Rutgers University which is
a hell of a title he taught a class that
are called politicizing Beyonce starting
in 2010 because our institutions of
higher education are the stupidest
places on earth and and Kevin Allred
tweeted the other day John McCain is
pretty okay with taking away everyone's
health care so excuse me if I don't have
a well of sympathy for his brain cancer
these are okay they're Democrats who
believe this sort of stuff hey Bernie
Sanders he says that he's not using
violent rhetoric with regard to trump
care but that's a lie here's Bernie
Sanders doing it over and over and over
again okay I want to talk about the
rhetoric done senator because if you're
going to sit down with people on both
sides of the aisle some Democrats have
branded Republicans the party of death
for example calling the tax cuts in the
Senate health care bills blood money you
yourself except Republicans are
potentially killing Americans is that
rhetoric irresponsible and does it
survive an impact to compromise but
you're going to sit down with those very
people that you've now said want to tell
people no I never said that stuff you're
using rhetoric that I didn't use
is an ugly and cynical proposal this is
a proposal which if adopted will result
in thousands of Americans felt enormous
pain and death the people all over this
country we're taking away thousands of
people who died of Americans robot ok so
then that was protected by Reagan
battalion obviously the Democratic
rhetoric comment is over-the-top to the
point where you're seeing people take it
seriously and as you know I don't blame
rhetoric for violence because I think
that there's always a contingent of
crazy people who are going to be
triggered but you have to say that it if
as I've explained this before if
rhetoric is a circle and then crazy
people are generally outside the circle
as you broaden the circle of rhetoric to
get more and more violence or closer and
closer to violence you're going to end
up triggering more and more people so
those people who are outside the circle
who wouldn't have been triggered by the
rhetoric they are going to be now
encompassed in a circle as the rhetoric
gets more and more violent I'm not going
to roughly blame Bernie Sanders for what
happened yesterday in Nevada but it did
have something but this sort of rhetoric
does make things more polarized it does
make things more volatile what I'm
talking about of course is Las Vegas
police released a video that has been
non-covered I mean if this had happened
to a Democrat would be covered all over
the media you've not seen it anywhere
right Las Vegas police released a video
from surveillance cameras this is from
senator Dean Heller office you can see
this fellow standing outside the
elevator over at Dean Heller's office he
left a note threatening to kill Heller
if he voted to repeal Obamacare write
the note actually said that if that it
said something like if you repeal
Obamacare I'm going to die and I'm going
to take you with me I this sort of stuff
is going to become more and more common
as the Democrats continue to maintain
that Republican policy murders people
and so you have to understand on the
left one of the reasons people are so
defensive of Trump is because the left
is so crazy if the left would stop what
their craziness then people might stop
defending Trump so ardently the reason
that the right is defending Trump is
because they feel like he's legitimately
under threat sometimes violent threat
from people on the left because of the
rhetoric that's being used okay so
before I go any further I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. at concealed-carry Association
so if you are deeply concerned
about somebody breaking into your house
Milne item breaks in your house you have
to take your gun you have to shoot them
this is why you need the US ECA so I am
a member of the u.s. concealed carry
Association here is the member resource
guide and they provide all sorts of
services for you I mean it's really a
fantastic list they provide you this
comprehensive legal and financial
protection in case you actually have to
shoot the bad guy right 100% upfront no
out-of-pocket coverage upfront criminal
defense coverage member benefits local
attorney coordination within 48 hours
expert witness coordination compensation
while in court right this is what u.s.
ECA does so not only do they educate you
and train you and they make sure that
you're legally and financially protected
for after you pull the trigger right now
if you go to defend my family now calm
you actually get not only you not only
get membership if you want it but you
also get five big chances to win 1776
dollars worth of guns and ammo defend my
family now calm if five big chances to
win 1776 right seven seventeen
seventy-six dollars worth of guns and
ammo they want to make sure that you as
a law-abiding citizen are armed and then
they want to make sure that you are
protected if you ever have to use your
firearm defend my family now dot-com to
check it out you should go and check it
out again they're listed services really
tremendous and it's something you should
think about in advance because god
forbid you're in a bad situation you
want to know that you're protected okay
so in other news in other news the OJ
Simpson parole hearing yesterday I think
that this is important because not only
is it one of the first things that I
remember as a kid I remember when they
wheeled in the TV for the OJ verdict and
I remember the the racial polarization
in our class all the white kids kind of
put their heads in their hand and all
the black kids in the class started
cheering when OJ was let off for
obviously murdering his ex-wife and
Ronald Goldman OJ had his parole hearing
yesterday the reason that this is
important is because this was I think
the very beginning of the complete
merger between politics and celebrity
people watch the OJ trial as total
entertainment to the point that now we
can actually make a series about the OJ
trial that's really entertaining the
People vs OJ Simpson and it has huge
ratings and Emmy nominations and it's
really good but it but this merger of
politics and entertainment it really was
I think the beginning of the rise of the
sort of reality TV star as political
figure because Ronald Reagan was an
actor but then he was the Governor of
California before he ran for
Oh Jay Simpson had been an NFL star and
then he was an actor and some of the
Naked Gun films and in the towering
inferno in a bunch of movies and then he
it mayn't commits this double homicide
these two slayings and everybody in the
world is watching this trial and
treating it as entertainment when it
really is not entertainment it's about
whether a man murdered two human beings
and the polarization that it brought off
the reality TV polarization was shocking
because remember this in the aftermath
of the Rodney King riots in Los Angeles
there's a widespread perception in the
black community in LA at that time and I
think still that the LAPD has race
issues I don't think that's right now I
think that there was some truth to it
then and the fact is that a lot of black
folks wanted to let OJ Simpson off the
hook not because they actually thought
that he was innocent but because he
killed white people and they didn't
really see why this shouldn't be a
referendum on the LAPD as opposed to on
Oh Jay Simpson the polls at the time
showed a plurality of black people said
that he was innocent it was obvious that
he was guilty from the get-go and in too
polarized that way that's a conflict
that has never really cooled down we
have the after-effects of it in Ferguson
we have the after-effects of it over in
over in Baltimore we have the
after-effects of it every time the white
cop shoots a black suspect or when a
white non cop shoots a black person as
in George Zimmerman and Trayvon Martin
in any case this is treated as sort of a
joke yesterday and it was kind of a joke
I mean OJ was convicted of armed robbery
for stealing some of his own sports
memorabilia in this is in 2008 he spent
nine years in prison
they had a 30 year sentence 33 year
sentence but this is treated as a joke
but it wasn't a joke at the time it was
really polarizing period in American
history and unfortunately in the last
few years it seems to have come back
again I want to show you sort of the
insanity of this because if you didn't
live through it it's almost impossible
to to know how crazy the OJ trial was
mean Malthus is a fair bit younger than
I am and I don't map to tells where you
went to happen we're even alive
why don't you happen when we were a year
old it was 95 news to Samantha is so
like I was I was 11 when this happened
and this is a major earth-shaking
incident if you didn't grow up with this
though you don't understand what it
meant when they cut into the NBA Finals
to show a white Bronco with OJ Simpson
and it running down the free with AJ
cowlings at the head and
a threatening to kill himself I mean it
was legitimately insane time so OJ
yesterday he goes to the parole board
and everybody knows that the sentence
that he got in 2008 was basically a
giveaway for it was basically Karma for
him murdering two people so he is it's
the monster of the pack when he watched
some of the testimonies demonstrative of
the fact that Ojo is a very stupid man
who obviously committed two murders and
was used as a as a central rallying
point for rates banners on all sides
here is OJ yesterday explaining why he
should be let out of prison well as I
said the alternative up to violence
courses I've always thought I've been
pretty good with people and I basically
has spent a conflict-free life you know
I I'm not a guy that had ever gotten to
fights on the street and with the public
and everybody but as that said they give
you a bunch of little tools about how to
talk to people instead of fight instead
of throwing punches tools that I've used
here that you know it's how he talked to
people tone that you use the victim
empathy was once again I I didn't really
see that okay he's led a conflict-free
life if you believe that OJ Simpson has
led a conflict-free life raise your
hands not so fast Ronda Nicole that's
just just amazing stuff and then he was
led off yesterday and so you understand
before this happened the parole board
took a selfie with oject so you knew how
this was going to go before it even
started and that shows you once again
the merger between politics and and
celebrity is really insipid and
disgusting it's why you now have Caitlyn
Jenner talking about running for Senate
in California it's why Ashley Judd
talked about running for Senate in
Kentucky it's why Al Franken is in the
Senate this is all part of the same
general phenomenon that celebrity is
celebrity a celebrity and political
celebrity is the same kind as everything
else Oh Jay was was granted parole even
though his parole hearing was really
went poorly I mean here's a clip of OJ
trying to he's supposed to be admitting
to his crimes right I mean this is what
you do in a parole hearing you admit to
your crimes and then you say well I'm
very sorry I did that and I'm never
going to do it again here is OJ talking
about how he never did anything wrong
they did an investigation and it came to
the conclusion that with my
property they turned it over to me I
have it now you know so I mean it's kind
of mine by a bottling that they turned
over to meet property that I'm in jail
for for trying to retreat you know with
my property I wouldn't never steal from
anybody and I would never ever pull a
weapon on anybody well you believe that
the property was yours you wouldn't put
a weapon on anybody like really legally
by the state of California that it was
my property they've given it to me
send it to me I have my question was why
you went to the sir I thought he was
yours can we stop it there no are you
with broll officers they're going to
clear him anyway because celebrity still
has enormous currency I love that I
would never pull a weapon on anybody
again you chopped two people's heads off
so I think the debt lacks a little bit
of credibility in any case I want to go
on to discuss what is the attempt by the
Trump administration to move beyond the
rush of stuff I also want to get into
entertainment I want to spend a fair bit
of time on the mailbag today so we'll do
a long mailbag today but you have to go
over to Daley wire for that so we are a
not just an audio show we are a video
show as well if you didn't know that you
should go over to Daley we're calm right
now you should go subscribe you can
watch the entire show live as it happens
you're going to want to watch the the
show today because we're actually gonna
show movie trailers that are
hysterically funny one is hysterically
funny one is fantastic I'm sorry about
Dunkirk and and I'll give you my review
but you have to go to daily wire for
that so $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription at daily wire it also gets
rid of the ads on the website you get to
be part of the mailbag watch the rest of
the show live its watching Andrew Clavin
show live you get to be part of his
mailbag get to see the new Michael J
Knowles show live which you know for
what it's worth anyway whatever but
you'll get to check it out should be fun
so go over there and check it out
ordering at the annual subscription for
$99 year and once again I bequeath to
you the opportunity to hold in your very
hands this indescribably great tumbler I
mean there's just no way to describe the
heft
the weight the value it's just for $99
you get all of those things and you get
this I mean this alone if Indiana Jones
had found this in a tomb
to the Holy Grail he could have known
that the Holy Grail was next to it and
he would have gotten this leftist tear
tumbler sure his face might have melted
away but it would have been worth it
because for just a moment his hands
would have beheld the glory that is the
leftist tears hot or cold daily wire
tumbler you get that with your $99
annual subscription so head over there
and check it out or if you just wanna
listen later iTunes SoundCloud Google
Play we are on all of those things and
you can subscribe and leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so uh so president Trump is
trying to get beyond all the Trump
Russia stuff it would help if he got out
of his own way but he is doing some good
things and I want to discuss a couple of
the things that he's doing so here is
that there's a report out that over the
first six months Trump promised that for
every new regulation that he made he
would cut to so far he is running
circles around that according to James
Baird over his daily wire to the tune of
16 regulations eliminated for every new
one proposed so the idea that Trump
hasn't done anything is not right I've
said before that what Trump did was
Gorsuch and cutting regulations that
remains true the 16 to one ratio comes
via numbers presented in a report this
week from the Office of Management and
Budget that shows the administration is
holding true to its vow to be business
friendly that's why you wonder why the
stock market continues to go up even
with all of the unease around president
Trump's behavior the reason is because
there's a general perception he's not
going to do too much to hurt business
and he's going to do a lot to help it by
removing regulations in Obama's final
year in office the Federal Register set
the record for the highest page count
ever at almost eighty two thousand pages
the administration is withdrawn remain
inactive a total about 800 proposed
regulations that were carryovers they've
identified nearly 300 regulations
related to energy production and
Environmental Protection and plans to
rescind review or delay across the EPA
and the Interior and Energy Department
this is a very good move by the Trump
administration that is something that is
worthy of pointing out and he deserves
credit when he does things that are
right so that is good also Mick Mulvaney
was out there yesterday the director of
the Office of Management budget and and
he is saying that it's time to push what
he calls mag anomic right to make
America great again anomic Kmag
Anonymous is basically just conservative
economics I mean like he's going to give
you a list of talking points at all the
things we've been saying for years but
now everything has to be put the
hesitant to have the Trump brand on it
listen I'm fine with that a proposed to
put its brand on good things and then
push them that's that's fine with me
here's Mick Mulvaney discussing what
they're going to do a tax reform oh I
bet the politics obviously is the art of
the possible I don't think we've given
up on that Oh a possible corporate rate
in fact I'd love to see a 15% rate I'd
love to see less but the truth of matter
is that we're still pushing for that
lowest possible corporate rate we can't
why you know the Democrats will
it's a giveaway to big business it's not
we're trying to get back to a healthy
American economy with the sign that is
3% growth we introduced the term this
week called mag anomic switch is sort of
this unifying thing of every unifying
theme of everything we're trying to do
to get that healthy traditional American
economy back on track and to have that
you have to have a lot of capital
investment you have to make people more
productive and that means businesses
need to invest more and that's what
we're shooting for on tax reform ok well
that's all good stuff and I hope to see
president from pursue that in order to
do that he's going to have to get out of
his own way as we say you know Spicer is
out scanner Moochie is in he's got a
whole new set of lawyers on the Russia
stuff he should put all that decide and
he should stop talking to the press and
you just pursue what it is that he wants
to pursue I think one of the problems
here is that he's not sure what he wants
to pursue but hopefully he can
consolidate around something so we get
some good policy out of this
administration okay so we're going to do
some things I like and some things I
hate they're almost combined today so
we're going to do we're going to do
things I like and things I hate before
we get to that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Skillshare
so if you are if you're in the job
market you know that you can't expect to
be the same company for 20 years that if
you are at a company or three that's now
considered a long time to work in a
company and when you move if you want to
have any upward mobility in your career
you're going to have to learn new skills
all the time well that's where skill
share calm comes in skill share calm
allows you to learn 15,000 different
classes design business and more new
skills you can learn a new one every day
there 45 minute classes things like
design and OB illustrator logo design
typography animation and photography and
marketing entrepreneurship branding Web
Design public speaking right
illustration and watercolor I've told
you this before but yes pathetically
enough I'm taking a watercolor class it
relaxes me folks but any case Skillshare
calm is the place where you can learn to
broaden your skill set that makes you
more marketable it means that you will
make more money in the marketplace
that's what Skillshare comm is for go
over to skill share calm right now you
slash capiro skill share calm slash
appear oh then you get a free month of
unlimited access once you've got it
you're not going to want to give it up
because it's just the learning doesn't
stop at skill share calm slash Shapiro
and that's where you can redeem your
free month again it is just a it's it's
a great place for you to to broaden
only your personal horizons but your
business horizons and hopefully that
results in a more lucrative a more
lucrative career okay time for some
things I like and some things that I
hate so things I like I saw this
yesterday and I have to say this is the
greatest trailer I have ever seen in my
entire life it is a phenomenal
phenomenal trailer it's Michael
Fassbender and JK Simmons and rich and
Rebecca Ferguson all these top line
stars and it's basically a serial killer
in Norway okay so they're trying to do
girl with the dragon tattoo and it's
really amazingly bad it's it's so bad
this trail like I love really like
Michael Fassbender is inaccurate like
I'll watch him in virtually anything I
will watch this with great enjoyment
it's called the Snowman and it is so
horrifying it's I'll play it then I will
explain why I love this so much it's
like a parody
a woman vanished last night
[Music]
we just found the body prints
IMed is missing the flopping fish she
calls himself a snowman hello mr. police
doesn't even say I'm thinking that he's
going off to women that he disapproves
off
the only thing we know for sure is that
he's playing games with us
yes okay so it's so great positive for a
second spawns from one second I want to
play more of it because it's so
wonderful okay so first of all it's like
they took every line from it from every
serial killer film that was the most
cliched and it's like it's like serial
killer mad libs like he's totally insane
the only thing we know is he's playing
games with us and then they took the
least threatening thing on planet earth
a snowman
right like the guy from like from frozen
like the Snowman and then they tried to
make this into some sort of intimidating
figure okay there's not even like clowns
which are creepy like an it okay you
have a creepy clown in order you to make
a creepy phone you can take something
that's like a childhood thing but it has
to be inherently a little bit creepy so
clowns are a little bit creepy just
inherently it's a person with a mask on
that's a little bit creepy just to begin
with but you can't take like Winnie the
Pooh and make Winnie the Pooh scary
there's just no way to do it right
even if you're going to do Chucky they
make Chucky scary it has to be like a
deformed doll we're like a cut on its
head like it has to be scary-looking
okay this is not scary it's just a
snowman and I'm like hello mister police
like it's so great I love it so much and
and I just love that Hollywood is making
films that like they got top name cast
because this is a best-selling novel
because people have no taste whatsoever
you know Dunkirk will probably open to
35 or 40 million dollars this weekend it
is the best film of the year this will
probably open to 35 or 40 million the
weekend that it opens and it looks like
it's going to be the worst film in
history I need to play a little bit more
of it just so you can hear that every
single line is a cliche I'm telling you
it's a cliche Madeleine's it doesn't
matter they took minds from like
insomnia and then they took a line from
from Silence of the Lambs
they took a line from and then they took
every serial killer movie they just took
a random line from and stuck in and I
have to play a little bit more because
you can't stop watching this it's so
addictive
we need a way to lure him out yes be
careful we don't know what we're dealing
with yes we don't know what we're
dealing with
another snowman
he's been watching at the whole time you
can watch it on there cutting things up
into little pieces
he's taunting us he's dancing and if we
don't find him this is never going to
stop Thank You captain obvious
another missing moment that's something
we're not seeing
if there's nothing we're not being
celebrate the way this has brought us
together
[Music]
anyone can see but he's trying to hide
something anyone can see that he's
trying to hide something okay I can stop
and start every single lie so the only
scary thing in the entire trailer is
like somebody with a mask on right
that's why you don't use snowmen as your
prop in a horror film with guys like
really it's a snowman like I'm waiting
to hear because it's summer like from
frozen right it just going to break into
that the Snowman killer oh so great so
thank you michael fassbender for
starting and what obviously is going to
be the worst film in human history
coming out in October I could not be
more excited about this and I will buy
17 tickets so I will be one of the
people making this four hundred million
dollars for the box office
I love it so much okay so now for
anything I actually really like and that
is I shut down Kirk last night I went to
the premiere last night at at the
ArcLight which meant I got a cool
dunkirk hat as well which is awesome but
in any case I will show you some of the
trailer it is it is a unique war film it
is not Saving Private Ryan it is not
Band of Brothers I'm not a huge Saving
Private Ryan fan I am a huge fan of
brothers hand it is very very different
film it is so creative and it is
brilliant in in a very different way
here's some of the trailer
[Music]
the enemy tanks have stopped why my
whisperers tanks when they can pick us
off from the air like fish in a barrel
there are 400,000 men on this Beach
[Music]
so it's really it's a gripping film but
it's not gripping in the way that Saving
Private Ryan opening scene is gripping
where you just get non-stop violent and
people's guts being blown out and the
randomness of it what you get from this
is something very different Saving
Private Ryan is done in classical style
it's sort of done like I always forget
the name of the the film that was
nominated last year a ridge what is it
hacksaw reg thank you I was mixed up
with the Heartbreak Hill or whatever
hamburger hill was the the Clint
Eastwood movie from the 70s I yeah but
in any case that film is he's done a
very classical style so Saving Private
Ryan you learn the backstory of the
characters and then it takes you in
narrative form through an entire you
know an entire arc to a logical
conclusion as to where this ends you
don't get any of the characters
backstories in this there's three main
characters or three main stories that
are followed one is called the mole the
mole is a reference to this bridge
there's at Dunkirk the province Dunkirk
was that I don't know where the British
surrounded but they were on a beach
where it was a bit too very very shallow
beach and the tide when it comes in it
doesn't come in high enough for big
boats to get in so a destroyer couldn't
get in and just pick up people instead
they had to have small ships trying to
figure things out and they didn't have
any ships because the British were
afraid that the Germans were going to
strafe the entire army and destroy all
their ships as well as there as well as
the Army on the beach thereby destroying
their capacity to resist and they also
weren't going to send all of their
planes because they did that then those
could all be shot down they wouldn't
have a capacity to defend London so it's
basically four hundred thousand guys
stranded on this Beach they can't escape
and so it is the loneliest most quiet
subtle war film I've ever seen when I
say lonely I mean like every shot looks
like that shot of the four hundred
thousand men standing and orderly queues
on the beach as though they're waiting
for ice cream but they're really waiting
to know what they're going to live or
die as they're being stripped from
overhead when people die it's not done
in like okay there's the in bandar
brothers or Saving Private Ryan fat
rumors like a leg over here it's
actually done in almost classical
fashion it's not a particularly bloody
film you don't see people you know with
their with their body parts torn off
because it's not the point of the film
like he just assumed that you know that
war is going to be bloody but what he
does do is he shows you almost the
casual violence of war and he shows you
the small actions by quiet people the
whole point here is that most of it's
amazing most people in America no longer
even know somebody who serves
the military presently they're about two
million people who served active duty or
serving active duty in the in the
military and there aren't all you know
serving on various bases but there are
lots of people who are in the National
Guard and such especially in places like
California and New York it's it's a good
shot you will your entire life without
meeting somebody who is an active-duty
military member and so when you hear
about a war what you think about a war
is not somebody who you know it's just
some disembodied person who is out there
doing heroic things to try and save you
and that's what this film takes on the
reason that you're supposed to care
about these characters is not because
you know where they went to high school
and who they fell in love with like in
like an axon Ridge it's not because
you're you know their personal views on
matters it's because these are people
doing her own things and making
difficult choices and sometimes doing
cowardly things and making terrible
choices in the midst of in the midst of
difficulty in order to survive to fight
another day and fight Hitler every you
make so many great directorial choices
in this film one of them is that you
never see the Nazis at any point in the
film there's no point at which you see
the Nazis the opening scene you see that
right the beginning of the trailer where
they're all walking through the town of
Dunkirk and they're there on the street
and these fliers are floating down
saying you're surrounded that scene the
very next thing that happens this isn't
spoiling anything it's the first 30
seconds of the film the the they you
just hear gunshots and they're
stunningly loud so unlike most war films
where they sound sort of just becomes
overwhelming in this film every crack of
a gunshot is stunning like it's
startling it's legitimately you'll jump
in your seat because it's so loud and
it's meant to do that because the idea
is that every shot is equally it's
equally possible that it's deadly and
going to kill you
and so they're walking down the street
these five guys as you see there and in
the first 30 seconds of the film you see
you see them getting picked off one by
one but you never see the Nazis at any
point during this film you never see the
Nazis the most you see the Nazis you see
some liftoff in planes that's it and so
the idea here is that these guys are
fighting an unseen force an enemy that
they can't control an enemy they don't
know and and yet they are having to make
these really really difficult decisions
so the three main stories are the one on
the beach as I mentioned there was one
by sea so the sort of Dunkirk is that a
bunch of civilian vessels were
commandeered by the British military and
civilians we're told to go sail across
the 26 mile stretch to done
kirk and pick guys up from the beach so
civilians who are non-military members
as men women just sailing across the
english channel to pick up all of these
members of the british military and an
800 800 different boats did that almost
a thousand votes did that and so it
follows this this one mark violence and
his son who are coming across to do that
and you never really find out until they
on why they're bothering to do it and
and then the third story is tom hardy
plays an RAF pilot Royal Air Force pilot
who is um who's engaged in these
dogfights and what's fascinating about
the film is that the mole right what's
happening on the beach takes a week
what's happening with the with the
sailor takes a day and what's happening
with with Tom Hardy takes an hour and
they say this up front and how these
stories meet up and are inter woven is
really fascinating
again the stylistic choice here is to
focus on the actions of the men not on
who the men are and I think that's and I
think it's a deliberate attempt by Nolan
so some people have found that
off-putting people have said that they
don't feel emotionally invested in the
characters because they're not being
given the backstory they're not being
given this whole thing but that's the
point okay you don't have to be
emotionally invested in who the soldiers
are who defend civilization in order for
you to be emotionally invested in their
fight for survival and their fight for
victory that's the entire point of the
film and it really is it's really a
first-rate film it's one of those films
where I walked out of it and it's kind
of stunning it's one of it's more of an
experience than it is a film and you
walk out and you feel like you'd
experienced something they should go see
an IMAX if you can I saw I didn't see an
iMac mm 70 millimeter and it's just it's
first-rate and the more you think about
it the better it gets the more you
realize the kind of directorial choices
he's making whether said that okay so
time for a quick thing I hate and then
we'll get to the mailbag so the thing I
hate is owed
JZ it has been rapping about his
infidelity and Monica Lewinsky loves it
this is really a thing okay so according
to the Daily Mail Monica Lewinsky has
now praised jay-z for speaking openly
about cheating on his wife Beyonce on
his latest album Lewinsky who
understands better than anyone the
public cost paid for a high-profile
affair spoke about the iconic rapper's
transgressions in an essay published by
Vanity Fair in the piece titled jay-z
Prince Harry Brad Pitt and the new
frontiers of male vulnerability the
former White House intern praised hub
for not ignoring the allegations hurled
to him by Beyonce on her 2016 album
lemonade jay-z had a choice Lewinsky
wrote having been called out publicly by
his wife in her fierce 2016 album and
video he knew his fans wouldn't have
blinked as his next album skim past the
allegations that's not uncommon for men
to do and it's not as if we hadn't seen
Beyonce and jay-z out of the world
together since then not to mention
welcoming their twins to Planet Earth
jay-z could have ignored it all but
instead he chose a path of candor that
will move the conversation forward and
help others know just know okay if
Beyonce wanted to stay together with her
husband then she shouldn't have been
talking about his infidelities publicly
and if he wanted to stay together with
her not only should you not be
committing infidelity he shouldn't be
out there talking about his infidelities
publicly because it's not a marriage in
my opinion that is going to end well
because marriages where the partners
talk about cheating on each other openly
is that that's not bound to go
particularly well it's scuzzy behavior
and some behavior can stay private okay
what happens between you interrupts
actually one of the one of the weirder
aspects of human nature is you'll see a
husband cheats on his wife may feel the
necessity to tell her there's nothing
more selfish than doing that okay it's
super selfish to commit infidelity in
the first place and then tell your
spouse about it is even more selfish
because that's about you alleviating
your guilt not about you making your
spouse's life better in any way it's
about you now creating a choice for your
spouse that is that your spouse never
would have had to make except for you
being an idiot and feeling the need to
jump off your own guilt on your spouse
so in when they said that honesty is the
best policy in these sorts of things
no being good is the best policy and
then if you do something guilty live
with your guilt don't dump it off onto
other people the idea that we need a
society filled with people who are
publicly proclaiming their infidelities
is really a bad idea okay time for some
mailbag let's do it so Josh Meyers has
been you discussing that neutrality what
are your thoughts on the matter in your
ideal outcome
capitalism fix it or leave the
government policies in place so I'm not
in favor of net neutrality net
neutrality as you'll see is B it's very
funny a lot of people who say the net
neutrality is basically a giant giveaway
run to companies that are ISPs Internet
service providers they neglect to
mention that net neutrality that the net
neutrality itself is trying to give away
to places like Google and Netflix right
there there are certain companies they
eat up all the bandwidth on the internet
and net neutrality forces internet
service providers to charge them the
same amount for data as it would charge
to anybody else as opposed to Cir
charging them for all of this okay
Internet service providers get to
compete with each other that would be
the idea the problem that we've had with
internet service providers is that there
are local monopolies that ensure that
there are only two or three at the most
companies internet service providers
they're actually in a particular area so
you're using a regulatory fix to fix a
regulatory problem what you really
should do is relieve all the regulations
on internet service providers in general
allowing people to build new
infrastructure and then compete in the
open market with one another because
there will be some ISPs the charge net
puts more and some that charge them less
there will be some ISPs that charge
small providers less and let them
compete and that competition will ensure
a better internet plus I mean the
internet seems to be working pretty fine
as it is I don't understand the huge
issues that people are having with with
the internet that they think it needs to
be fixed by some sort of overarching
government system next is your been
which state is your least favorite and
since we're on the topic of California
why do you live there it seems like a
hellhole so California is a beautiful
place that is government like crap it's
I live there my entire life the weather
is really nice most of the time there is
some culture here despite all the talk
about black there of which state is my
least favorite it's hard to say state I
can tell you cities that I really don't
like so I'm not a big fan of New York
City New York City I it's fun to visit I
would hate to live there I like seeing
the sky I'm a suburban guy I grew up in
the suburbs so hard for me to live in
New York but the state of New York is
great I go to upstate New York is
beautiful there are real areas of New
York that are just just wonderful
michael says hi Ben I recently watched a
video by Jordan Peterson regarding job
suitability for different IQ levels he
raises the point that society never
really addresses what to do with people
of low average intelligence regarding
jobs
what are your societal prescriptions for
those people in the workforce since
constant mechanization is leading to
demand for more and more skilled workers
thanks
this is actually a really really good
question so this I think is the big
question of the future of the workforce
the truth is machines are good at doing
some manual labor but they're not good
at doing all manual labor so machines
are good at varying doing very
specialized manual labor
like at factories right if it's doing
one thing over and over and over
machines are really good at that what
machines are not really good at is doing
many different tasks so for example you
can have a Roomba that cleans your floor
but it's not gonna be able to clean your
table right so if you a person can do
both of those things so manual labor is
not going to go totally out of style for
people who are not you know Phi Beta
Kappa and actually need to work in
manual labor but yes we are going to
have to develop skill sets as
mechanization creates less need for
manual labor there is going to be a need
for more creativity in the market the
good news is that IQ doesn't always
match up with creativity so there's a
lot of people who are very creative who
aren't necessarily world's brightest
people just look at Hollywood so we're
all going to have to up our skill sets a
little bit I don't think the market has
ruled out you know low IQ people at this
point when it starts to then we are
going to say if we get to the plant so
this before if we get to the point where
machines are basically providing such
abundance that everybody is there's no
need for the there's no need for markets
because markets are created by scarcity
if you have the replicator from Star
Trek and it just creates everything that
you could ever need then you don't have
to worry about things being created
anymore and then you talk about a
universal basic income Tyler says why is
it when a person from Western country
converts to an Eastern religion they are
considered enlightened when a person
from an Eastern country converts to
Judaism or Christianity they are traded
to their culture this is a very good
question the answer is because there is
always a bias against the religion with
which you grew up in Western
civilization if you grew up in an area
where everybody is conservative you
become lefty then you are considered a
lightened member of the upper class by
people in the big cities and the same
thing is true with regard to religion
you are you're moving beyond your
boundaries
never mind that if a person from the
east converts to Judaism Christianity
they are considered a heretic very often
or they're considered a rube that's just
because we as a society have learned to
hate ourselves in a lot of ways Evan
says in what circumstance do socks go
with candles so as someone who used to
wear socks with sandals and found it
extraordinarily comfortable when I was a
teenager
I will say in situations in which you
are not publicly seen that would be that
would be the proper answer because I got
to tell you I'm not a big sandals fan in
general particularly for dudes right
dudes should not wear sandals cuz feet
are ugly so like dude feet not something
people want to say put on some shoes
that like it just looks melyandd
terrible like please don't do that okay
Chris says last year Ted Cruz voted
against bills to increase veterans
benefits and it hurt his standing among
us is it intellectually dishonest to say
the veterans group deserve entitlements
due to the nature of their service as
opposed to other groups so I am not
aware of Ted Cruz's votes on veterans
benefits I'd have to look that up to
confirm whether that is in fact true but
the general question to say that
veterans deserve entitlements due to the
nature of their service no I don't think
that's had a balance at all I think
that's part of the contracts when they
sign up right you're telling them to go
do the most violent difficult job on
planet Earth in many cases and you're
going to have to pay people a lot of
money for that including lifetime
benefits in some cases it Kyle says hey
Ben how did you know you're ready for
kids what advice would you give to a
young couple out of colleges - how to
know when they are ready for kids so two
things one you're never truly ready for
kids okay kids are you can make the
decision that you think that you are
financially prepared to take care of a
child that's really what it was for us
we were in a financial position where we
were ready for kids and we felt that we
had the time and resources to properly
care for our children so from a logical
perspective that's true but when people
say ready for kids the implication is
I'm not ready for kids than I should
just not have a kid and the fact is the
most kids who are born are not prepared
for lack should you should you prepare
if you can yes you should make sure that
your relationship with your spouse is
ultra rock-solid because having kids
changes the nature of your relationship
with your spouse before you can focus
only on the other person in your
marriage and now you both have to focus
on these new people who take over your
lives so you better be solid before that
happens so if you're financially you
know on the upswing and if you are and
if you are solid with your spouse and
you can safely say you're ready for kids
but if you're not ready for kids that
doesn't mean that you can't be a good
parent or that you can't become ready
for kids or that it can't help you grow
as a human being and that you take
responsibility for decisions that you
make that says hey Ben my little sister
is 13 she like most kids is very caught
up in today's culture and politics
because their idols tend to be liberal
she's been developing a more liberal
view of the world chardee tends to look
at conservatives in a bad light I was
wondering if you had any advice on how I
could go about helping her understand
service isn't better without alienating
her I'd appreciate it so I think the
first thing to say is that you know it's
it's not good to label people you don't
know as bigots without any sort of
evidence that they are bigots okay
you're tolerant of all sorts of views if
you consider yourself a liberal you
probably are conservative because if you
consider yourself liberals because you
want everybody to be able to do it they
want basically at the libertarian
position not a leftist position
okay leftist like to say that about
sexual matters the right doesn't really
even care about that stuff anymore okay
libertarians don't even care about that
stuff if I care about it on a religious
level I certainly don't care about it on
a governmental level or on a public
policy level so you know I think that
she probably has a skewed view of what
the right is because she's listening to
people from the left the answer should
be go listen to some people from the
right and that way maybe you can
determine whether what is being said
about those people is true or not Alec
says what is your position on mandatory
tipping I think the original tradition
of giving a tip in advance for better
service made sense but everybody demands
a tip for everything regardless of the
level of service so I am a pretty
generous tipper
I am ideological ideologically opposed
to tipping so I both of these things are
true I am generous tipper because I
think when people work hard they deserve
money and I'm happy to give them that
money however tipping is stupid okay I'm
with Dwight Schrute from the office on
this one I don't hit my proctologist and
he's doing something more important than
carrying my food seven feet from the
counter to my table so this idea that
you get a special tip because you carry
food seven feet like how about this I
would rather you make a better wage and
charge me more for the food then that I
have to decide whether I'm a good person
or not based on the tip I give that's I
mean there really is what we do right
they've actually found this they've done
studies of this of tipping it's really
fascinating and what they found is they
thought that originally people did
tipping because it was reciprocal
altruism that if you give a tip
somebody's going to give you a tip back
but then they found that that makes no
sense right you never see the way to
again you never see these people again
it's just that you don't want to be
perceived by that waiter as a bad guy so
you give a tip so there's a moral
judgment that's made about you based on
the level of your tip and you're making
moral judgment about your waiter based
on you know did they do a good job in
are they a bad person I'm going to give
you a two dollar tip just to show you my
grandfather used to do this we didn't
like the service use of it nickel right
just to show them they didn't like the
service again I don't think that any of
this is relevant we all earn wages out
here in the in the non tipping world so
I'm not a huge fan of tipping although I
will say that
I think that if you're an employee is it
- it's a great way to make some extra
money it's a way really what it is is
it's almost become a way to avoid taxes
because hips are generally given in cash
and if you're a waiter you can make a
lot of money on the side that way okay
david says hey Ben well the fellow Game
of Thrones fan sometimes I have an issue
with the over-the-top sex and violence
is there a way you justify the graphic
nature of the show are we just huge
nerds who are willing to accept it so
both yes the over the top section
violence is over-the-top sex and
violence over-the-top violence doesn't
tend to bother me very much because I
think that there are situations in which
violence is is necessary so the
over-the-top violence in bandar brothers
doesn't bother me really because I think
there are situations in which violence
is necessary and violence against evil
is necessary and we should all see the
wages of sin are death and we should all
see that that you know bad things even
happen to good people but when it comes
to the graphic sex in the first season
for example and it is very graphic the
first season is basically near
pornographic I had problems with that I
fast forwarded through a lot of that
because I thought that it was just HBO -
and what HBO does every HBO show just to
prove that their HBO and they're there
pay access they have some boobies just
to show a look where HBO and we can put
boobies on TV and now they've decided to
up the ante and so oh where HBO so we
can put a dinghy on TV you know this is
this is what they do so I don't think
there's a way to justify it I think that
you can say overall the show's great I
think you can fast forward those things
I think that but I'm not going to
justify what I think are bad artistic
choices there are situations in which
nudity on screen is is is actually
useful to the story so I think of two
cases in particular of Clockwork Orange
where there's some nudity on screen but
it's directly designed to demonstrate
the the evil and vulgarity of the
villains and and their inability and and
and what the brainwashing program has
done to this one guy afterward and
there's another movie called the
pawnbroker anything I've recommended on
the show before with Rod Steiger
about a Holocaust survivor and there's
one scene where he runs a pawn shop and
a woman comes in and she bares her
breasts in front of him and it's used at
the gateway for a flashback to his wife
was in a concentration camp with him and
she's being raped by a Nazi officer so
they're there there you have a case but
both of those cases typically are not
erotic right both of those cases are
rape scene so I think in rape scenes
very often you have to show that stuff
in order to show how vile and evil rape
is and why rape they should be castrated
Raquel - the most
people on earth but in terms of like
erotica you know showing erotic stuff on
screen I don't think that's hardly ever
necessary in fact the most romantic
scenes of all time are rarely sexting
those are your the most forgettable
right the romantic scenes are the ones
that are from the 1940s where you know
people barely touch and the tension is
just tremendous that's the most romance
and sexual tension not sexual release
and it seems that most of today's movies
focus in on sexual release not sexual
tension okay so we will be back here
next week next week I will be traveling
to Washington DC to testify before
Congress and we'll give you all the
updates on Berkeley as of Monday right
now Berkeley is saying that they are
going to try and give me a slot they
pledge that they will make the event
happen so thank you for all of your
support folks and hopefully they'll
fulfill that pledge we'll see they kind
of jerked and Coulter around so we'll
see if they took me around as well but
hopefully they'll keep their pledge
we'll give you the update I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]